[Music]
train is a wish your heart makes when
you're fast
[Applause]
[Music]
in dreams even lose your heart
[Music]
whatever you wish for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's obnoxious screaming is me yes
this year I got to go to e3 and so much
more but first of all let's be Rhine so
I can explain to you how you be soft
changed my life and why you should never
give up on your dreams I've never been
shy of saying that Beyond Good and Evil
is my favorite game yes that did you see
me in very old Q&A so it's probably
gonna have to be Bianca's evil just
because it was the first game I ever
gone very excited about as a kid I had
enough great let's move on
even though Beyond Good and Evil wasn't
very known at the time it opened up my
eyes to a whole new world of gaming it
showed me new elements that led me to
being immersed like I'd never
experienced before
not only was Jade an awesome female
protagonist but there was a wealth of
characters music gameplay elements such
as sneaking racing fighting flying
taking pictures of animals I'd never
experienced a game that could give me
the riot II in terms of gameplay but
somehow keep it simple and make it feel
real Beyond Good and Evil offered a
surprise around every corner not to
mention the dark and very real
subject-matter of trafficking and
government corruption that it brought to
light I was pretty young when I played
this but this had quite an impact on me
every emotion was felt excitement
frustration sadness elation serenity
fear I played many games since this one
but hopefully put no game has stuck with
me quite as strongly as this one leading
me to take up film and photography at a
very early age but eventually finding
myself with an urge to learn the
concepts behind game development for
myself detroy recreate the same intense
imagine that Beyond Good and Evil gave
me from this slow-motion fight scene at
the very start of the game I was hooked
it pretty much shows what the rest of
the game is about to entail adventure
action excitement but also such detail
to make you really pay attention to the
beauty of the game and that's what I
love about Beyond Good and Evil
[Music]
as years past youngin evil - was teased
again and again but unfortunately led
nowhere
until we fast forward to e3 2017
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think we can all relate to this Thank
You Michel and because of this I had to
write a song I just knew I had to so
from that day on I started writing
lyrics in my spare time and my breaks at
work I've worked with my producer Jamie
at Horizon productions and he created
green eyes some of you might have seen
it but it was a song about Beyond Good
and Evil 2 and how excited I was for it
[Music]
now I didn't really think it would go
anywhere but my coworker at the time Kai
from Kai creative took him out he's a
really good photographer he told me that
maybe I should try and send it to
Gabriel Schrager and see what comes of
it
she is the narrative director of Beyond
Good and Evil 2 and I just thought why
not sent her a message on LinkedIn and
she replied that was enough for me but
it doesn't end there fast forward a few
months and I find myself in France
[Music]
I've been invited to be part of the
Beyond Good and Evil Community League
leaders program where they basically get
the the biggest fans are Beyond Good and
Evil together to do workshops about the
next game which i think is pretty darn
awesome it's such a good idea that
they're actually reaching out to their
fans their community and seeing what the
people want from Beyond Good and Evil -
I just think it's really good and
genuine approach to it and also it takes
balls because they're trusting us not to
spill the beans so obviously I won't be
able to tell you anything that goes on
in those workshops because I can't but I
also just want to let it be known that
Ubisoft are doing something like this
and I think that's so good because for
me it's kind of unheard of for them to
just reach out to their fans this early
on and be like okay we want this to be
such a good game what do you want it's
very cool it's really cool and a lot of
people are here from the forums online
and things because they talk on there
all the time and we're all just massive
Beyond Good and Evil fans so we could
just chat about my favorite game with
some people who feel exactly the same
way being here it's so inspirational and
then knowing that I will soon be in the
presence of Ubisoft is pretty
mind-blowing I'm actually really
overwhelmed
[Music]
[Music]
it's been amazing I don't want to break
their trust by saying anything that I
can't say so all I will say about this
is that I think it's such a great idea
that they're getting their fans involved
in such a way it's really overwhelming
when you fall in love with the game and
it's not even the fact that I fell in
love with Beyond Good and Evil which I
did but it helps shaped my career path
that helped me realize what the gaming
platform could be for me yeah I just
think without that I wouldn't be where I
am right now but anyway that's not the
point the point is is that they feel so
strongly about this next game they want
to get it right so badly that they've
invited Beyond Good and Evil
biggest fans to just come and talk to
them about just the game and being
excited and getting our opinions and
views on things and they are just as
passionate as us and I think that is
amazing
I understand what they're doing is such
a huge risk but I really appreciate it
and I respect them so much I want you
guys to know that that they really do
care about this game and not only this
game but the others that they make as
well they talk about them also
passionately and it's it's so beautiful
to be around people who really
appreciate what they do and they love
what they do and they they love games
like they get it they are gamers and I'm
meeting wonderful people as well it's
not just about me it's I mean some
really great people who all share the
same passion as me and we get to talk
about our favorite game together and
it's just great do you like that so good
yeah I'm happy it was not the end just a
few months later and I was singing to
myself in an airport ok fine whatever
and on my way to Los Angeles as a
Ubisoft star player so I'm gonna try and
vlog my experience of being a Ubisoft
star player
it started off crazy I don't know if you
actually got to listen to the footage of
me being in the Mexico air corps nope it
turns out you can't hear that but I got
sent to Mexico City because my flight
got canceled I was just sitting on the
flight you know ready to go ready to go
to LA you know where trade my feet and
fortune for my fame and fortune and yeah
I just got cancelled and we all got told
to leave and I was like oh okay but what
down what do I do
so I had to wait in customer services
for like hours
buh-bah along so sure Ubisoft a freaking
amazing
I don't know how they did it but they
made it so that I could get there for
the Ubisoft conference
because that was the main thing and I
took so much footage of that I'm sure
you've either already seen it I'll put
it in after this but I am so glad I
didn't miss that conference so glad
because oh my gosh it's amazing I mean I
didn't want you to cry no don't cry like
I'm so I'm so jet-lagged okay yeah
don't judge me this isn't me going over
the top although I am crier I I cry when
I get overly emotional like if I'm angry
or really happy I just cry and I cry a
person a crier present and just I think
I'm still very overwhelmed because I
literally came from Mexico yesterday so
I was happy I got something some food
cuz you know you can't go wrong with the
Mexican food but anyway I stopped my
food and start to worry actual
conference it was honestly a dream come
true I mean I was sat there in in the
crowd just looking at the stage just
knowing that usually I'm at home
watching a bar now why am i crying this
is just really overwhelming and like in
the best way possible
these are happy tears I promise
[Music]
yes just it's just really nice I like
trying to put make it a little crying
this I go work this is not gonna work
it's just really refreshing to see like
how much Ubisoft really do care about
the players the game is the people that
love what what they make and to see the
passion and dedication that goes into
just saying thank you
it's really inspired me to like once to
be not only like making games that's
kind of taken over now like of me just
playing them for the fun of playing let
me get what I mean and that's going to
start because actually the communities
that get made the friendships that get
made they're the kind of bond that you
share with people who not only play
games but play the sorts of games that
you play because everyone plays games of
different reasons right and once you
meet up with someone who has such a deep
love for something that you also have a
love for it's hard not to to form a bond
with them I've got ten minutes anyway so
I'm gonna stop my my lamb balls quickly
slap this on my face and then run
downstairs to have breakfast with the
Beyond Good and Evil team I'm just so
happy to be here and thank you to
everyone for supporting me I'll probably
do this again later when I'm not when
I'm not like feeling crying
I'm not feeling cray I'm not feeling
emotional or as emotional because I
think this whole experience it's just
one like emotional rollercoaster that is
freakin amazing but anyway sorry about
the weird shot I'd kind of Pumped you up
somewhere and I know the lighting isn't
the best but it's probably for the best
now because oh my god my makeup is going
everywhere cuz I've been crying ok
should stop don't take the piss out of
me I'm an emotional girl okay that's
what makes me unique see ya okay enough
emotions back to the fun stuff
[Music]
[Music]
yesterday we went to e3 finally and I
posed with Norman Reedus not the real
Norman Reedus
I wish anyone else oh my gosh before
that had this awesome thing where you
get put like into a vault it wasn't
actually playing a game but it was like
experiential and I love that type of
stuff but unfortunately we didn't queue
up and then by the time we got back they
weren't letting anyone else in
today we're going back to the Ubisoft
lounge because that's what we were went
a little over went after e3 oh my gosh
guys I played the division two last
night I'm really bad at those types of
games but actually it was super fun
because even though I'm not like a big
shoot-'em-up action player kind of
person it had a lot of details that I
really didn't expect like we were
playing and obviously we could hear each
other through the headsets and then I
just this little deer and then it
started to run away I was like guys dear
thank you oh my gosh such an idiot I
named also trials I forgot how much I
love trials because if you have been
following me for a while you know that I
started gaming because I loved racing
car games I used to play them all the
time as a kid all the time and then
trials was right up my alley it was just
so much fun and I used to play with my
friends when I was a kid and we used to
just be really competitive about it and
I'm no way as good as it used to be but
it's so so much fun it I mean it's just
nice to play a game sometimes they
literally switch off just just switch
off and just get lost in trying to be a
high school so that was really fun
the camera with me in trial Bank trial
today is my day actually I'm gonna be on
the little Ubisoft lounge stage talking
about the hit records partnership with
beyond evil 2 which is the community
thing and I've also got a separate video
to upload about that create something
and we're gonna be showing it today and
then I hope people like it and I hope
you like it too when I put up that video
I'm probably put that one up before this
one actually so you've probably seen it
I hope you like it
um faith in your traits and some tea
your rainbow will come smiling
[Music]
no matter how your heart is grieving if
you keep on believing
that dream that you wish will come true
[Music]
created a we need to work even more
openly with you the game because we
won't be back together everything gets
better so crazy for America if you're
passionate and you have a dream then
don't give up don't be discouraged to
share what you love online create until
your heart's content because you never
know who might see what you put out and
you might be given a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity
I just want to thank everyone who helped
me get to where I am today and obviously
Ubisoft for really appreciating what
everyone does around their games and for
giving us this opportunity I met so many
wonderful passionate inspiring
individuals and all of you made this
trip
absolutely amazing thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]